clap clap
there's enough to worry about when
you're a new parent
[Music]
s getting to see your GP when you need
to shouldn't be one of them on that
phone call the 8 A.M Rush it's always
sort of justifying you know he's very
little he's you know he he's been very
poorly and you feel like you have to
explain and almost apologize for why you
need to take up the doctor's precious
time
relax myself
it's pressure that builds up when demand
Rises and the number of GPS Falls a
government pledged to recruit an extra 6
000 doctors is set to fail
NHS leaders say new initiatives can
spread that workload by allowing
pharmacies to prescribe drugs for common
illnesses like earaches sore throats and
shingles patience won't need to go to a
GP unless they actually really need to
see a GP and instead we'll say 15
million appointments over the course of
the next two years for those people who
really do need that access
but there are also fewer Community
chemists now than in 2015 and
pharmacists say their services have been
squeezed by Soaring costs every Pharmacy
across England is underfunded to the
tune of about 67 000 pounds a year
currently so this new funding will
really help pharmacies to deliver more
for the NHS but there is still a lot of
pressures there the plan will see 645
million pounds retargeted to pharmacies
over two years
the plan also means that patients will
now be able to self-refer for physio or
Podiatry appointments but every sector
is struggling with staff shortages and
is looking to the government to publish
its Workforce plan for answers
the wheels on the bus go round and round
both Ava and Alexander are happy healthy
babies but their mums hope the next time
they need to see a GP it won't be as
stressful and difficult as it has been
oh she's Joshi Sky News in West London